How could intelligent work with physical
data?
Video recordings, sensor data, robots
telemetry, and sometimes all of those
combined in a single multi-model
project.
If you try this, you probably have seen
how badly it fails. And today we'll
discuss the reasons
and all the physics laws
behind the problems and how to fix it.
This year two frontier labs published
very interesting results and surprising
results that agents in general are not
good at data.
Uh, Anthropic published that accuracy
for data projects on their agents is
only 21%
until you add specific data harnesses to
them and provide context.
OpenAI published a whole
layers of context, six layers of context
in order to make the data agent to work.
And all of those are unstructured
data which lives in a very houses with
tables, execution engine, and all this
like luxury.
In my life, I don't have this luxury
unfortunately because I live in a very
extreme side of the data universe, messy
unstructured data.
Uh,
I work with data for about 10 years. I
built data version control project, Git
for data, and now work on data chain.
In order to make agent to work for
unstructured data, for physical data, we
need to build not only the brain which
we already have, right? It's LLM.
Uh but we need to make harness data
harness
to for agents to understand this
physical world. It should see the data
properly. It should be able to run kind
of giving him a leg. Uh it should be
able to touch data, verify the result,
run tests, and also remember
the crucial important data sets,
important result. So, this information
could be reused
uh in the future project.
And the first we start from the how you
see data.
Uh what does it take to understand all
these complicated binary files that you
have in your object storages?
Uh
in reality, how it usually looks, uh
they are
just a several files, sometimes several
thousand of files, right? It doesn't
seems like a big deal, right?
Uh but
what is usually happens,
those files are very complex inside.
That what makes unstructured multimodal
data complicated.
And from 2000 because video recordings
might have
clips inside. Clips might have frames.
Frames objects. Objects confident, type,
class, label.
Uh
there's connection between those pieces
together.
It makes kind of like explosion. It's it
looks like uh
neutron star.
It
small size on the surface, right? It's
just a size of a one city.
But the mass of this object is
tremendous. It's more than the mass of
our sun.
Uh and what 2000 objects, 2000 files of
videos could easily generate you
millions of objects inside the videos.
And how people usually do deal with
these problems? They usually go through
like a two major steps. First step,
let's put this meta information to JSON
files and put it on S3 next to the
images, right? And they end up with a
millions of JSONs.
Crazy latency, not efficiency, not
consistency.
And the next idea,
why don't we use database?
Brilliant. And the most advanced team do
exactly this. Let's put a centralized
database when all the meta metadata is
uh in there.
Great.
But this way you end up with a two
system with a two programming languages
and all the mess around uh two different
stacks. And this stacks
useless for most of the researchers
because they don't want to deal with
this complexity.
We found that the easiest way for
researchers and developers to deal with
the schema is Pydantic. Uh so you use
the same language for the data, for the
schemas, as well as code.
Uh there are no SQL island in your code
base.
So in a that way you kind of transition
from the messy world of structured data
to the structure.
The only thing you need to just like
transpliers to the SQL uh from from
Python and I'll show you
uh how it works. But that's the way when
you can create schemas uh and work with
the schemas efficiently. I want to
emphasize that the problem we are
solving here it's very specific for
structured data, physical data. It
doesn't exist in the structured data
world, right? For example, in those uh
OpenAI and uh Anthropic blog posts
because they work with the structured
business logic, right? We work with the
physical data,
binaries and such.
Let's see how it works.
I will be showing you our open source
project data chain
with data harness to coding agents.
So, first you need to install the tool,
right? Using pip install. So, we have
already done this.
Then,
skill needs to be installed. So, you
choose the coding tool that you use. We
will be using cloud code. But, we
support three more different uh
coding agents.
And then, you run
your favorite coding coding agents.
Uh of course, we are skipping
permissions.
Uh
just to make it faster, right?
And then, you define the prompt and just
solve your problems. So, in this case,
we will be analyzing
uh motions uh in video cameras.
Uh that's open data set from
um
uh dashcam recordings.
Uh
video it's a very usual use case for uh
physical AI projects.
Uh majority of the project
do include uh video recordings uh as a
one of the modalities. Sometimes, the
major modalities.
Uh and that's one of the I would say
more interesting and more challenging
problems to solve uh in this uh physical
AI world. Let's use uh this modality as
an example.
This data harness asks
uh some questions from users to
understand the scope better.
So, in this case, it uh we need to
choose the model. So, it decided to use
a YOLO model and we need to choose the
size. So, let's use the smallest one.
Uh
we need to
choose the velocity.
Uh so, there's a few ways how to track
like speed.
Uh but, let's use the simplest one. So,
the second one
uh adds more
uh will require more time
for the compute. And, granularity, so
per detection frame, per track.
Uh let's do just per frame in this case.
And, the data set itself. So, we ask for
January data, right? 91 clip, but it
also ask for
uh if we need to extend scope and
uh analyze more images.
So, let's let's stay here.
So, it took us
24 minutes to analyze those
uh 90 videos.
And, now we have all the information, we
can ask uh
questions about it. For example,
how many
um
videos
have
people in it?
This information lives uh in the
database, right? As we discussed, and it
can very quickly query this database and
return the result, right? So, okay.
uh oh, 82 out of 91 clips have some
people
uh detected, right? And uh
you don't need to kind of go through all
the JSON files
download and analyze and parse, right?
Information is here in the local
database. It can easily
quickly answer the question.
We can even see the
source code.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, just that easy and nice
Python code
to get get data get data data set,
right? Analyze apply some
simple filters
when label is equal to person.
Count
the number, right? And then see the
total total number. And it goes like it
runs against database so super fast.
So, how big is
how many
records do we have here?
So, that's about the size of our
neutron star, right? It's not supposed
to be big because we analyze only like
90 videos and 90 videos generated
100,000
of records, right? So, that's how
explosion is happening.
If you analyze
thousands of videos, right?
It goes to like a million
million scale and if you go to deeper to
the objects,
it can easily
it can easily be multiplied by 10 20
even hundreds.
Let's take a look at the source code.
This code was generated by the
agents.
Uh power agents using the harness.
Uh
The magic part here is the data model.
So, this data class uh
that was generated based on our
requirements and
it's a just a by dentic uh usual by
dentic data model.
Uh
with the file.
Uh right, the video file. Uh
frame ID, timestamp,
uh class ID, that's how you know if it's
a personal car or some object,
confidence score, bounding box, there a
few more items here.
And the object is nested.
If you look at the If you take a look at
the bounding box, right? There's a
several columns, but
files is more interesting. One.
Uh file has uh path and the checksums
like a
version of the file, e-tag, size of the
file. So, everything that's your cloud
storage providers provides for you.
Uh and this information is just become a
row in a database
uh instead of a JSON file in S3.
Uh that's why you can easily uh
answer
uh all the uh questions.
Uh all the analytical questions, right?
Like before we asked how many people are
there. Uh and it's just a matter of like
a simple Python code that runs against
the database
uh to return like results super quickly.
Uh that's how you can
make sense of all the messy data you
have on your storage, right? In a file,
uh but you analyze uh you analyze this a
using using regular analytical
tools and
two tricks.
With the schemas, you can see what is
inside the object. You can see the scale
of the problem. But, how to do the
actual heavy lifting when we when we
deal with the terabytes of this messy
data?
You do know that
the data harness have to have execution
engine in order to deal with
physical data.
It has to work efficiently. Sometimes it
spend a lot of resources
and tokens
if you sell them.
And if it breaks somewhere in the
middle,
so you should be able to recover and
catch up with all the data that it's
already processed. So, you don't want to
waste your resources.
In the sequel or structured data world,
execution engine is your data warehouse,
right? That's obvious and easy.
In an unstructured data world, you have
to reinvent one.
And in some teams, they use different
types of orchestration tools or
distributed computer on Ray or Spark. I
like model of Dask which
connects
computer with the data structured data.
But, unstructured data needs its kind of
like own approach when you connect the
Python and schemas with the execution
engine.
To simplify it,
you can connect those Python functions,
Pydantic schemas, input input
parameters, output parameters for the
function, as well as the data warehouse
with all the meta information and files
on the storage all together in a in a
holistic experience. Uh that's what this
way it will be more simple for
developers to code
and it might be simple for the engine to
distribute jobs to different machines or
different threads based on the files
they process, the schema they produce.
Uh so forth and so on. It's kind of like
a Dask approach if you wish but for
unstructured data world.
To make the execution efficient, uh you
need to run this uh
data processing data crunching function
very efficiently, right? In a parallel
way or distributed way.
And we use data models and the data
storage models a lot. So, it kind of
connects the file which is a file in
your S3 bucket
uh
to the result
uh that's a set of detection object
which goes to the data warehouse, right?
So, this function connects the storage
and the data warehouse in a regular
Python way. Uh so, that's a very
typical Python code. There are no like
extra assumptions about this code,
right? We don't even use like annotation
for the function. It's just a function
with a specified types. So, the types
are important. Uh
and all of those are PyDantic.
And result
you just generate
uh generate the objects
and the
engine connects all the storages and uh
warehouse together, right? That's how
you define the parallel
uh parallelization layer. You can say
uh Uh, I just need to run it in
40 machines, right? That's how easy it's
supposed to be for is your chance to run
like a distributed computer, right? You
just specify how many resources you
need, so you got it.
And the function itself, right? So, we
just use it
run it through generator or it can be
like mapper with one-to-one function,
one function.
Uh, one file returns like one object to
the database or generator, one function
returns like multiple objects in
database. And it is saved as a like data
set, right?
Uh, uh,
table under the hood, uh, in your
uh, database.
Processing of those heavy files usually
takes a lot of time.
And sometimes it's very expensive
because you use LLM in order to
understand what is inside
uh, of your binary files.
And the last thing you want is to lose
this compute.
It's really sad when you process
uh,
hundreds of thousands of files
and it fails in the middle
because of bugs or API call issue and
you want to execute everything from
scratch, right? You are losing the whole
half of this compute and sometimes doing
this over and over again.
Incremental update
and data checkpoints it's a must-have in
this data world.
If you fail,
you fix the bug, run it again and catch
up all the result that you have already.
If you got more files in the bucket,
uh, you run the script again and it gets
only the new files and uh,
update data based on the new computer
only without recomputing the
the other stuff.
Running tests is a very fundamental part
of coding agents. They do this all the
time for quality control, for reasoning,
to better understand what is around in
their universe. It's kind of like a
hands of your
agents, hands of your
uh harness.
In data,
running test is super
slow
process.
And how to do this? Because quality and
accuracy of the questions it's even more
important in the data question data
projects
compared to software projects. Uh as
Anthropic put it in a right way in
uh software projects, there's a lot of
ways how to you can solve a particular
problem.
In data, there is usually only one way
and only one current correct answer
uh to solve the problem.
How to answer questions very fast
on your
binary data mass.
And first of all, you should stop
running all this like complicated Python
scripts on top of raw data. That's the
most expensive, the slowest way of doing
this. Instead, you need to organize
layer of meta information over like data
sets uh or tables around this uh raw
data
uh that could answer these questions
very quickly.
And this something that data industry
knows for like a dozen of years.
It's a dimensional multi-dimensional
data modeling
uh star schema, one big table approach,
and all this like fancy theories around
around this. And we need to use this
more in order to make our unstructured
meta data processing uh to be more
efficient.
And we actually incorporated these
techniques inside the agents. And when
you ask a question,
instead of answering the question right
away,
agent ask itself, do I have a proper
data sets, proper metadata to answer
this question quickly in a single like
SQL-ish query. And if not,
it tries to build this layer. It tries
to make sure this layer is general
enough to answer not your particular
question, but a set of questions
related to the one that you asked.
And that's where you are building these
layers and layers of information that's
could be reused by you and your
teammates.
Now, you spent a lot of time,
a lot of resources to compute those
useful slices of the data,
and you can use those to answer some
interesting questions
uh efficiently without really running
expensive compute.
And guess what?
People are doing the same job over and
over and over again.
You're paying double, triple, quadruple
price to solving the same problem.
So, if you discover this
neutron star or black hole, it's better
to share this information with people uh
so they won't be wasting their resources
and their time
uh to doing this stuff.
And coding agent, as well as data agent,
doing this
those tricks with memory a lot.
Uh your coding agent like Copilot,
Codex, PI knows a lot about your source
code, about with all the indexes
uh and such.
Uh on the data harness, you need to
build and provide this context uh to
your agents.
And that's not only the fact that hey,
there is a data set, you need to provide
a lot more information with this.
Uh
why this data set was built, kind of
like a context from the session.
Uh description of the data set, which
usually enrich by LLMs, source code.
Probably the most important part here is
the source code. Uh that's one of the
conclusion in OpenAI data agent blog
post.
Uh and this information needs to be
exposed uh exposed in a way
like knowledge base. Some way that can
easily be used by agents, by people. Uh
so you are not wasting this time over
and over again.
And the knowledge base is organized in a
very traditional way, I would say.
Uh just a set of MD files, right? So uh
you see this is how it looks like in the
in my directory, but when I get more
data sets. So the data set that we
created, that one.
Uh
this is the MD file.
Uh so description of the data set,
right? The session context. Uh so why
this data set was created based on the
discussion. Dependency to the storage,
to the directory that we pointed uh to
in the beginning. Uh preview of the
data. Uh very useful information to kind
of
have a
sense of the data, this schema.
Uh some stats on the data.
And the source code.
Uh as we discussed, the most crucial
part uh
to understand uh what is
data is about.
And all these pieces together, right? Uh
the
source data, right? In the bucket, the
source code
uh in the knowledge base, and the result
in the
uh in the data warehouse, create like a
data lineage, right? So, everything is
connected. Agents knows everything. If
you share the knowledge graph, then all
your teammates already know about this
uh about this data set, about the
resources you spent in order to process.
So, next time if someone ask question
about this directory, uh
the recompute won't happen.
Uh
agents will be using uh your your
result, uh the result which based on
resources that you already that you have
already spent, right? That's the magic
of the uh data harnesses when agent
knows everything about your data.
Let's put all the pieces together
in a single stack.
In the bottom of the stack, there is
some huge mass
of your
unstructured physical data in object
storages.
No one makes sense of this data, and you
need to run expensive compute LM calls
to extract some meta information through
the compute engine,
and organize this meta information in a
data sets, in a data set slices through
the some uh data set GB.
Knowledge base is a way how you
share this information.
This is a world when your favorite
coding agents, such as Copilot, Codex,
Cloud Code,
do not operate efficiently.
Their intuition pushes them in a wrong
direction
because laws of physics
changes.
And in order to make it, you don't use
stronger models. Everyone use frontiers.
Instead, you are building data harness.
Data harness that understand
the laws of this physical data.
And that's the way how to make your
favorite coding agent efficient with
these problems.
We implement some of those principles in
Data Chain project, which is open
source.
So, please check it out and put some
mass on your agent.
Thank you.